i can't get into it i can't get into the
music at all sony is challenging apple
with their own open earbud design so
today we'll see just how good it is and
how it compares to apple's new airpods
3. i have been absolutely loving these
and i've been using them exclusively for
the last few months i gave my airpods
pro to my wife and they sound amazing
but these sonys have this weird design
with a little hole cut out in the middle
it's supposed to let in sound that's
from the natural world plus they have a
couple really cool tech additions which
we're going to talk about along with
comparing not only the sound quality and
comfort but also the microphone quality
and the additional features so let's
jump right in and start opening this up
sony has moved to an all recyclable
design for all of the packaging and then
with that the actual buds themselves are
made from recycled plastic so it doesn't
feel as nice as far as materials but it
still looks pretty cool but let's go
ahead and pull out the actual case all
right that is very unique i thought the
case was going to be larger based on the
pictures but let's set that aside and
i'm gonna pull out just this little uh
recycled box here we have a very short
uh usb type-c to usb a charging cable
and then somewhere inside of here we
should have a bunch of ear tips at least
the little wings that uh hold them into
your ear because you do need to have a
nice secure fit the case quality feels
quite nice and it's interesting to see a
little button that's kind of like a
latch for holding the little top open so
let's press that down oh there we go so
it's not magnetic but it doesn't really
pop up that well okay maybe it's getting
better now and then look at that those
earbuds look so
weird and wait a second do they have a
little pin
yeah they have a little pin that holds
it in there let's do a little test let's
drop these
okay so that is a positive compared to
the air pods uh with these
okay well it didn't work that time
a lot of times you drop it your air pods
go flying and of course we have a little
magnetic case so it's easier to open it
looks like sony fixed that issue with
this little latch and then with the pins
that hold him in the footprint of the
link buds case is smaller but then if we
look at the sides this thing is thick
that is much thicker and i wonder why
because in terms of battery life the
link buds only get about 17 and a half
hours of total battery life compared to
30 with the airpods three so that means
almost double the battery life now the
buds themselves they get about five and
a half hours compared to six for the
airpods three and we have one other
difference the airpods have wireless
charging built into the slim case
whereas this thick case for the link
buds does not have wireless charging
built in now you guys let me know how
big of a deal is that for you for me
personally i love being able to just put
this down on a wireless charger and have
a charge without having to plug in
instead of having to get a cable and
plug it in that way now as i mentioned
i've been using these quite a bit they
are super comfortable they fit well in
my ear they don't fall out now let's go
ahead and see how these really really
weird or interesting earbuds fit in my
ear so this is the right one
slip it in and you gotta get the little
hook there they feel a lot lighter than
the airpods three now based on the specs
sony advertised these at four grams and
the air pods they are like four point
two four point three basically the same
weight but maybe just because of the
shape and how they fit
you feel them a lot less now i'm gonna
start out with the air pods first and
we're gonna go through three different
tracks different styles of music now of
course air pods three have regular
drivers built-in good ones and these
have that little weird driver that only
uses the edges with the hole in the
middle very very weird so i'm excited to
see how it sounds like let's start with
the classic
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
all right guys
wow i was not expecting that at all
angelica did you hear these
yeah you heard them then why can i
barely hear them this is
wow okay what do i say
if you like listening to music
i would have a really hard time
recommending these headphones i expected
it to be less bass maybe because that
little cutout than the airpods and these
are tuned really well for bass even
though they're not sealed in and they
get loud where these
not only was it really lacking base the
volume i tried turning up the phone
multiple times it was maxed out ahead of
time i tried going to the app it was
still maxed out over here i went through
all of the equalizer settings
and tried to adjust it even when you're
bringing up the brights which typically
makes it louder that is
crazy
how what does it sound like to you
angelica not as loud as the air paws but
still loud you still heard them yeah
because for me the airpods sound like
they're twice as loud let's go ahead and
switch let's try a different song let's
switch to another genre this is a modern
classy instrumental song
[Music]
really good bass
[Music]
oh no
[Music]
i can't get into it i can't get into the
music at all
[Music]
i'm sorry sony
[Laughter]
oh god who are these for
okay let me put these back in okay can
you talk to me they're advertising that
they want the live your connected world
online and the real world to morph
together so you can listen to music but
also pay attention what's going on and
talk to people at the same time
hey max how are you doing
okay yeah you sound normal you sound
normal okay
so can the airpods not do that enough
how you doing max
there there there's absolutely no
benefit
to these
compared with this hole in the middle
it doesn't sound any better at all but
the music sounds so much worse
i don't think i've tested an earbud in
the last
three four years of comparing earbuds
that sounded this
bad this kind of reminds me of going to
the dollar store and buying like the
earbuds that you buy the wired ones for
a dollar that i bought for my kids for
the airplane
that's what this reminds me of i mean i
know what sony was trying to achieve
with these they're high-end earbuds
they're pretty bulky they seal in your
ear
and this is a light minimalistic one
that's open just like the air pods
but why would anybody buy this compared
to the galaxy beans or the galaxy buds
live
these things also they're open design
they're a little bit heavier but they're
comfortable you can still hear your
environment pretty well and the sound
quality is so far ahead i mean it's not
you can't even compare them and let's go
see on amazon right now look at that 99
brand new
and look right below sponsored sony link
buds that is hilarious don't spend 178
on these link buds if you don't want to
buy air pods which you can buy and use
for your android phone we've made
multiple videos about that though if
you're not getting air pods get these
samsung galaxy buds live they advertise
active noise cancellation but it doesn't
really do much but they're great if you
want this style of ear but it's
something that is very unique it looks
different all right guys we are going to
skip the next song that is way more
difficult than what we just played that
usually makes headphones start falling
apart but these can't even reach those
normal levels but i will go ahead and
put them back in and we will do a
microphone comparison this is a
microphone quality test using apple's
airpods 3 in a normal indoor room that
does have some hvac noise this is a
microphone quality test of sony's link
buds in a normal indoor room that does
have some hvac noise sony made a really
big deal about their microphone quality
so you guys make sure to listen that a
couple times let me know down in the
comments which one you think sounds
better we just took a listen to the
recordings and sounds like the airpods
focus a little bit more on the higher
frequencies where sony is a little bit
more on the lower both do sound good and
the sony's are definitely good as far as
the competition as far as mic quality
for android or just regular third-party
earbuds now the link buttons do have
some very cool features the first one is
how you control them with the air pods
we have that stem that you can press on
double press press and hold things like
that and with these they knew they
didn't really want people tapping on it
because when you do that kind of gets
out of your ear so you literally tap
on your face or the side of your head
and right there it just
unpause my music
i'm going to tap two more times
there you go a pause it and then in your
settings you can actually go through and
you can adjust what those functions do
so it's kind of weird tapping inside of
your head but it does work really well
and the earbuds stay secure now you also
have adaptive volume control which is
cool if it gets louder in your
environment they will get louder to
compensate and then we also have the
really cool function where when you
start talking it will actually pause
your music and then as soon as you're
done having a conversation say with the
junk over here they will start playing
again that is a function that i really
wish my earpods 3 had but even with
those cool features
personally i would not be buying these
because i do care about sound quality
and that's actually why i use the
airpods 3 over the pros because they do
sound more balanced they do sound
better so these things cost
180 dollars the same price as airpods 3.
of course airpods 3 can pick them up for
10 bucks less on amazon right now i'll
leave links down below
but the battery life is quite a bit
worse the talk time is almost half you
don't have wireless charging
and the sound quality you can't even
compare it's not even close personally
i would not purchase them i would
purchase earpods or another alternative
like samsung's galaxy buds live which
you can buy brand new for just a hundred
dollars check out my review on those
right over there and you guys let me
know your thoughts down in the comment
section below click above to subscribe
this has been max and i'll see you in
the next video
[Music]